we were not expecting to see you here
tonight why is that I've never missed
one before and I'm not gonna miss one
now
yeah it doesn't surprise me truly we
should shoot you up Oh y-yeah why that's
a good question I think you should ask
them she did leave a question for all of
you guys to answer though me guess why
how do I know what is your response to
why you're gonna have to watch this show
I mean all I know is I spoke my truth
and that's all I'm gonna say and that
you have to watch the show and find out
I've heard to say why we every every
single person in this cast could say why
except because I had to tell the truth
that's a good question you'd have to ask
her that question why did she stop
showing up and why did she stop throwing
up there we go all right why would all
she said is why why not my man
I don't know why not because that's
almost comical what is the question
I guess I'll throw it back and say why
she has a question why I feel face yeah
why not come back and hang out with us
[Music]
you